STEVE: I'M NOT SURE I CAN
THINK OF ANYTHING WORSE THAN
ACTIVELY SUPPORTING THOSE WHO
TRY TO PREMATURELY SEXUALIZE
CHILDREN BUT THAT IS A BIG
TECH AS DECIDED TO DO.
PAYPAL AND THEN MOW THEY TALK
ABOUT THEIR VALUES JUST SHOT
DOWN THE ACCOUNT OF A GROUP
FIGHTING BACK AGAINST THE
PREMATURE SEXUALIZATION OF
CHILDREN AND AS THE NAME
SUGGEST THAT PEOPLE BEHIND
THEM ARE GAY.
PAYPAL IS TARGETING THEM
DESPITE ITS HISTORY SO HERE IS
SOME RAINBOW FLAGS BECAUSE IN
THE HIERARCHY TRANSIT AT THE
TOP AND NEVER TOO YOUNG TO
START.
AND THEN TO CANCEL THE GAZE
THAT THESE ARE NOT MADE BY
ANONYMOUS CORPORATIONS THAT WE
NEED TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
SO WE REACH OUT TO THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE BOARD AND THE CHIEF
CORPORATE AFFAIRS OFFICER TO
JUSTIFY WHAT THEY DID.
OF COURSE THEY REFUSED BECAUSE
THEY ARE PATHETIC TALENT THEN
THEY HIDE BEHIND CORPORATE
GOBBLEDYGOOK WHICH IS ON THE
SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
BRAGGING ABOUT WINNING
MULTIPLE OF WORDS ADVOCATING
ON BEHALF OF WOMEN AND GIRLS
YOUR SUPPORT FOR PREMATURE
SEXUALIZATION IS ATTACKING
THEM SHAME ON YOU.
MOST LIKELY THE PERSON WHO
SIGNED UP GOING ON ABOUT
SERVING VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AND WHAT HE REALLY MEANS THAT
PAYPAL SUPPORTS PRAYING ON
SEXUALIZING VULNERABLE
CHILDREN AND IN THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE BOARD WE MET HIM BEFORE
ALSO CEO OF NAGY - - NAGY IS A
BRAND FOR CHINA AND BY CHINA I
GUESS SO IS PAYPAL ON CHILD
SEXUALIZATION AND FOR CHILD
SEXUALIZATION.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS WRONG
WITH THEM AND THAT THEY
SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGE THE
ABUSIVE MONSTROSITY BUT DO LET
THEM KNOW WE WANT TO HEAR THE
DEFENSE JAMIE THE NEWS ABOUT
THIS WAS REPORTED BY THE
ADVOCATE ACT BANNING GAYS
WHICH IS THE ANTI- TRENDS HATE
GROUP ARE YOU?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON
BECAUSE THAT OPENER WAS SO
SPOT ON KNOW WE ARE NOT ANTI-
TRENDS PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY ARE
IN HER ORGANIZATION WE LAUNCH
DAY COALITION BECAUSE SO MANY
PEOPLE WERE COMING TO US TO
SAY I WANT TO BE A PART OF
THIS HOW CAN I?
SO WITHIN TWO DAYS OF
LAUNCHING NOW IT'S CURRENTLY
STILL BAND SO ANYBODY CLAIMS
THAT WE ARE IS DISINGENUOUS
AND THEY ARE JUST USING THE
TRANS PEOPLE TO PUSH THE
AGENDA THAT IS ANTI- HATE OR
I'M SORRY ANTI- TRANS BIGOTRY.
STEVE: GOOD FOR YOU FOR DOING
THAT.
SO TO LAY OUT THE MISSION YOU
FEEL THE SAME WAY THAT AND
LOVE WHO THEY WANNA LOVE.
AND THEN TO MAKE THAT VERY
CLEAR.
>> THAT'S ALL THE CARE ABOUT
WE ARE NOT TRANSFER BUT WE
DON'T CARE ONE -┘- TRANS PHOBIC
WE JUST DON'T WANT THIS
HAPPENING TO CHILDREN.
AND THEN TO PERTURB THE KIDS
OTHERWISE IT IS KNOWN AS
MUTILATION OF CHILDREN BUT
ALSO TO WE CLAIM OUR STANDING
IN SOCIETY HOW WE WANT IS THE
EQUAL RIGHTS AND THOSE WHO
HIJACKED THE COMMUNITY MANY
ARE NOT EVEN PART OF THE
COMMUNITY PUSHING THIS THROUGH
AND IT MAKES ALL OF US LOOK
BAD I WANT TO SHOW THE
MAJORITY OF GAY PEOPLE AND
TRENDS PEOPLE AND THEN TO TRY
TO SAVE OURSELVES.
STEVE: GOOD FOR YOU.
SO WHAT HAS HAPPENED HERE IS
THE MOB WITH CORPORATE AMERICA.
>> NO DOUBT THEY HIJACKED THE
MOB GAY AND STRAIGHT AND
PARENTS OF ALL AGES YOU CANNOT
GET A TATTOO UNTIL YOU ARE 18
YEARS OLD YOU CAN HAVE A BEER
UNTIL YOU ARE 21 THAT YET WE
ARE ALLOWING HOSPITALS TO
OPERATE ON 14 AND 15
-YEAR-OLDS AND CHANGE THEIR
BODIES FOREVER?
IF YOU ARE 18 YEARS OLD LIKE
IT OR NOT YOU ARE AN ADULT AND
SOMETIMES THEY MAKE DECISIONS
WE MAY NOT AGREE WITH.
IF PEOPLE WANT TO MAKE
DECISIONS AS AN ADULT THAT IS
FINE BUT THE IDEA THAT WE
MAINSTREAMED 14 AND 15
-YEAR-OLDS WHAT THEY ARE
TREATING KIDS FOR NOW IS
WILDLY PROJECTED BY THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY.
AND THE FACT THE GROUPS LIKE
YOUR GUEST IS DOING FANTASTIC
TO BE SILENCED EVEN KNOW THEY
ARE SPEAKING OUT SHOWS HOW
OFTEN WE ARE HIJACKED BY A
TINY MINORITY POPULATION.
STEVE: 100 PERCENT IT IS
AMERICA THEY SHOULD LET THEIR
VOICES BE HEARD IT IS
OUTRAGEOUS.
WHERE CAN PEOPLE SUPPORT YOU?
>> THANK YOU PEOPLE CAN LEARN
MORE WITH ALL OF OUR SOCIAL
LINKS IN THERE IS WAY TO
SUPPORT EITHER THROUGH
DONATIONS AND I WAS HAPPY TO
REPRESENT I APPRECIATE YOU
LETTING ME TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
THEN HAPPENING BECAUSE IT IS
UNJUST THE MOST UNIFYING ISSUE
ON EARTH WE'RE A NONPARTISAN
GROUP IS MUCH AS PEOPLE TRY TO
WRITE THIS OFF AS AN ANTI-
RIGHT WING HATE GROUP AND WE
HAVE MUCH MORE SUPPORT THAN
HATE AND COMING OUR WAY BUT WE
HAVE THE MAJORITY OF THE
POPULATION AND CENSORSHIP SO I
JUST HOPE WE CAN WIN SOON
BECAUSE IT GETS WORSE EVERY
DAY.
STEVE: YOU ARE DOING A
FANTASTIC JOB.
HERE IS ANOTHER FANTASTIC
EXAMPLE FOR WOKE EXTREMISM
LISTEN TO BARBARA GEORGE WHO
IS RUNNING FOR SCHOOL BOARD
NEWPORT BEACH IN CALIFORNIA.
>> I DID A PRESENTATION THEY
WERE GOB SMACKED BECAUSE THEY
HAD NO IDEA THIS IS HAPPENING
BECAUSE THEY KNEW NOT TO TALK
ABOUT THESE ISSUES SO THEY ARE
IN THE DARK A LOT OF THEM CAME
UP AFTERWARDS AND SAID THANK
YOU BECAUSE WE HAVE NO IDEA
THIS WAS HAPPENING SO I CAME
AGAIN SPEAKING ABOUT THE
CURRICULUM AND I TOLD THEM
WHAT THAT ENTAILS APPARENT
CAME TO ME FRIGHTENED AND SAID
WHAT DO WE DO TO STOP THIS?
YOU CAN GO TO THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK
THAT THEY DON'T IF THEY ARE
AFRAID FOR WHATEVER REASON TO
STAND UP AND BE AN ADVOCATE
FOR YOUR CHILD SO PLEASE GET
INVOLV